All right, welcome
back everyone to
the ninth meeting on May 12th.
We're in the third of four sessions
overall on chapter two.
And it's the second week of chapter two.
Then we'll head into three.
There have been several updates over the
last week.
So, I'll briefly share those updates.
Then we'll look at the questions table
and look at the chat, see if anybody
wants to just ask a question and we can
start a new one or look at the
pre-submitted.
So, um
a couple days ago
I pushed this update to GitHub active
inference institute/fundamentals.
And it it's just one starting structure
for the code base that we'll make in
kind of open source parallel to the
book, which which as we know we can't
directly screen share and we don't have
all the methods to regenerate the
figures, but they might be available.
And uh
this is what
pops up locally when you run
uh these commands.
There's each chapter will have a tab. We
can make these chapter tabs very rich
with a lot of fan fictional material,
fan science fictional material.
Um
and the uh
package
layout is like this.
SRC is like a software package, all the
source methods. So, these are the kernel
methods.
Then scripts
are thin orchestrators of the SRC
methods.
So, in other words, we're not making a
hard-coded standalone notebook just to
regenerate like this figure for chapter
two.
But rather we're reusing methods. So, as
we continue through the chapters
the SRC will be like our toolkit, like
library of composable, modular, tested,
documented functions.
And then we'll have these thin
orchestrator scripts, which means like
no new methods are defined in the
scripts folder.
And then those can be various
demonstrations
and um
make the difference visualizations or
other things that we kind of find
useful.
So, hopefully that sort of breaks the
third, fourth, fifth wall of the
textbook
because we can start to move some of the
questions that people are asking
and the ideas and like the edges between
ideas that might be in the textbook
highlighted as a key point, which would
definitely be good ones to know.
And then also these um
like adjacent textbooks,
which are like the kind of personalized
learning that we all essentially have to
engage in and can engage in
to connect the dots between how we want
to understand a given topic
or how given topics are related.
Um
and we can use the questions or just
other channels of requests
to circulate or like YouTube comments or
something to circulate like could we
visualize this against that?
Um
I don't know if a live vibe coding
during a recorded session per se is the
um
uh most efficient or guaranteed to
succeed live, but certainly the requests
over the time scale of like tens of
minutes, like several to tens of minutes
with a prompt or few,
it is very possible
to be like
making adjacencies to what already is
there, especially.
And going further, too.
Um
so
hope that this repo can be for those who
already know how to do code
and get
useful.
And uh maybe we can have sections that
like import PyMDP or other existing
frameworks.
So that
as well as maybe have
one or multiple standalone
reimplementations.
Because that's
also interesting to look at. Like and
and there's
not saying this is the stable
morphology at all.
We can break things out but we'll just
try to make sure that that the main line
is functional and like regenerates
everything that is supposed to
regenerate.
Um
and kind of keep it
with one contact point to the textbook.
Like yes, if you were going to make a
software package that was doing
something
much more
sophisticated
you might have generative model might be
there might be several subfolders of
methods with a whole different approach
and and posture for just specifying this
category.
But here this might be sufficient
for like an educational package that
just highlights the core elements that
like must be included and doesn't
obscure it within many lay- layers of
like abstraction and
other kinds of programming methods which
can be very powerful but they
um
put a little distance a little more
distance between the formalism
and the code method.
But that may be totally appropriate
in a given project.
So
if there's any comments or ideas or
questions or anything on like code or I
mean how should we utilize code in this
group this
interval.
>> Yeah, Andrew then anyone else
write in the chat or raise your hand. Go
ahead.
Well, thanks. Uh yeah, just briefly if
there's anyone here or anyone who's
watching the recording in this meeting
who wants to be involved in code
development, whether they want to follow
that particular scheme or you know, if
they're still sort of getting into
programming and are not quite sure where
to start or if there's a particular
concept they saw in the textbook that
they thought was interesting, but
they're still kind of wrapping their
head around it or trying to understand
it would like some kind of coding
example, you're totally welcome to to
reach out. Uh either yeah, first going
to the the code page in the coda that
that Daniel's currently on here
um or or sending us a message or or
email or otherwise, it'd be very cool to
build out code that like one directly
addresses um sort of what what people
are trying to learn or what what they're
interested in. So, yeah, that's all I
wanted to say.
Yeah.
Like it kind of
I don't know if it goes without saying,
but this is a kind of applied
oriented textbook.
And we're going from making it like a
culinary history to being the cookbook.
If we actually have the methods
and once you have some opinionation
about how your code base looks,
like how do you create a new generative
model or how do you just um do it do a
visualization?
You can drop in a single prompt
to a sort of agent harness like a cloud
code type format
or point um even a graphical user
interface like the like a desktop
application, point it the repo,
and then like ask
different things. And especially if it's
a if it's a close adjacency,
like you just want to see this, but with
a different
or you want to say and then like this
describes how the difference
figures
are being generated, which you can trace
back.
However, this kind of signposting makes
it really easy for a coding agent to
trace back
and signpost.
So, like
make make
this
type of image,
but could you adapt this for height and
weight?
Or here's a couple columns from a CSV
file I have.
Could you plot that data on this kind of
a plot?
And then people can kind of share their
their curiosities and and what they
prompt and what they get
by by asking those like
kind of adjacent
uh
questions to the code base.
And that's facilitated by having There's
other code base design practices and
like so there's not meant to be a like
saying this is the best in all formats.
But having a separate
like this is kind of stir,
crack the eggs, open the refrigerator,
and then scripts are just like the
recipes, which are kind of like pseudo
code.
And they just dispatch other
methods,
mostly.
So, if people have things that uh
they want to suggest or they want to
see,
then over the 2 weeks that we have per
chapter,
um like
we should be able to
do it. Even just being able to state
what you would want to see is basically
usually the prompt that's good enough to
make it happen.
It's going to be like a secondary uh um
question if you want to extend it to a
large data set or get some um
state-of-the-art performance on some
benchmark or something. Like that that
still may be a ways away from the base
model, but for these
core statistical concepts,
and and being able to ask what if
related to these core statistics ideas,
this setup or even a blank folder is
usually a good starting point.
Any other like
um Terry, where can we see the chat
after? And we could uh make a
we can make a column
for chat.
So we can upload that.
Whoever downloads it to myself or who
whoever, um Fraser or Andrew, just
remember that like also the direct
messages will be in your export if you
download it from your own.
Or I don't but I don't think the the
cloud version I don't think stores it.
So it yeah. Fraser?
Yeah, I just wanted to maybe
contextualize how I'm thinking about
make you know the code examples and
things like that. I think it'd be great
to have a uh like a package or a module
or something that can be reusable. Uh
you know, where we can exact one example
into another example bit like you were
saying just then. But initially I really
the focus I think should be around like,
you know, how do we reproduce partic-
particular examples? How do we reproduce
you know, example 2.3 and 2.4 where
we're looking at oh, the difference
between you know, a generative model
that is in fact uh veridical, you know,
it has the right generative model versus
one that has a mismatch. Um I think the
best place to start would be to try and
reproduce the examples in the book.
That's And you know, you can do that ad
hoc. You can do it however you like. Um
I'm just I'm replying to a question here
in the chat about, you know, will we use
pymdp?
Um, we certainly can. Uh, we have no
kind of commitment as to what we should
be using, particularly pymdp, rxinfer,
whatever. Um, although I will say
initially, [clears throat] you know,
we we're trying to get our hands Well,
trying to get our heads around the the
core abstractions of active inference.
Um,
and and packages like pymdp, they're
very powerful in the sense that they
uh, they kind of hide a lot of the
detail from you in some ways. Uh, and
they they they can be good for that.
But, um,
it's probably best to start out with,
you know, base numpy, you know, really
really quite basic uh things and
implement everything from scratch. Um,
so that that's my perspective on what it
means to get going with the examples.
So, that's something I want to start
looking at. Again, we haven't had we we
we're only just beginning to even make
contact with particular concrete
examples in the book now. Uh, so it's
something that will happen going
forward.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Like as the name sort of suggests, this
is a
uh and Andrew wrote it would be good to
revisit pymdp during the discrete active
inference chapters in those sections.
Yeah, absolutely.
So, this is kind of the the trade-off
frontier between like a less
opinionated, more generic modeling
framework, like any number of a variety
that can use uh any Bayesian network.
But, then there's often a lot of like
middleware that you need to get to
specifying specific distributions or
certain distributions are aren't
accessible. And then on the other end of
the spectrum are more like these
high-level interfaces like pymdp,
which are only trying to run a subset of
situations and generative model families
and such. But, for those, they can offer
really good support and good
documentation.
So, having these standalone
uh implementations of core methods,
especially
some basic statistics methods,
can be cool to see like, "Oh, that's
just a couple lines."
And there's other statistics package
that might be like more performance
or or be a more generalizable approach
to handling different distributions.
Certainly, there are.
But,
from this repo or from this example, you
could always
prompt a coding agent,
"Okay, now adapt this logic into this
statistical framework."
And that will often get very far cuz
like the the bigger picture articulation
about the typing of the models is
is the part that gets the details filled
in.
So, hopefully we'll uh, we'll we'll see
how it goes week by week.
Um, but we will try to, by the end of
the two weeks,
have
some of the things discussed
uh,
so some code shown or generated for
methods in the book and others for
things that we come up with.
Okay.
Terry, I'll copy your question in and
then anyone give their thoughts on it.
>> [laughter]
[clears throat]
>> And then we'll look at any other
chapters, but this is like a meta
question.
I wonder if anyone else feels like we're
in a space where nothing makes sense.
I'm trying to understand how we get to
Q(x) while a lot of this discussion
sounds like I should already know the
whole book.
Could we get an overview of things like
I'm a 5-year-old, I'm not a coder? What
does anyone want to say to that or I can
give a thought.
I sometimes feel like nothing makes
sense, too.
Pleasure. Thank you.
>> [snorts]
>> Uh yeah, just real quick. I mean, um
this is exactly how I felt when I
started messing around in active
inference, and I I did have a background
in maths and computer science, and even
reinforcement learning, which is a
similar kind of field. I was, you know,
there were there were many, many
interrelating ideas that it was unclear
how they interrelated with one another.
I'll just say that that reason is the
reason why I'm very enthusiastic about
in my sessions having a kind of
structure for
uh elaborating what is the core idea in
the chapter, what are the sort of, you
know, pre-V things that we're seeing now
but are not fully explained, and then
what are optional things.
Um
I I think it's very important to
to at least be able to understand
qualitatively the core ideas before we
move on to other ones. So,
I'm not sure that
that helps you in your particular uh
case, but the um
I think it's important to, if if nothing
else, get an appreciation for what is
the core idea, you know, in this chapter
here, and then you can you can take that
as far as you can and want to in terms
of the the technical how that falls out
in the technical aspect of things.
Uh but it's not really
it
you know, if you don't understand the
core ideas, there's there's there's
there's no there's not much point trying
to run with the technical material. Um
and you're not going to understand it
the first time around, either. So,
in some sense, you're damned if you do
and damned if you don't. But, um
I don't know if that was helpful or not,
but that's that's that's the reason why
I'm structuring things the way I am in
the coda. People can let me know if they
they like that or not.
Nice.
Yeah, it's uh it's I mean, active
inference, and not just active inference
but adjacent sort of fields and
frameworks can
sometimes be notoriously difficult to to
wrap one's head around so I very much
agree with Fraser's point of kind of
building up
from from fundamentals rather than
assuming that we're going to understand
this all at one time. I do think it's
really important to be able to build up
a little bit of an intuition for these
things before before jumping into the
mathematics unless you're someone who
already has a formal background in
mathematics and and Bayesian frameworks
in particular.
I mean to attempt to address that
particular question like how do we
arrive at Q of X
like there
potentially two answers we could say one
of them is the more intuitive sense of
okay I'm a person I receive sensory
information and then I update my beliefs
about what's going on in the world,
right? That's my Q of X in a sense. I'm
I'm updating my beliefs about X about
the environment about the world about
whatever it is using information around
me and I can act in the world and elicit
further information
if I'm still trying to figure out
whatever's going on. that's a slightly
more intuitive way of phrasing it. For
those if the question is more centered
around like the core mathematics of like
wait a minute how did we get a Q
whenever previously we're looking at P's
in the sense of like probability
distributions. It's there that that the
mathematics does become a little bit
involved and the short answer is by
using certain kinds of properties in
mathematics of logarithms a few other
things that appear like they they might
appear initially to be like tricks.
There was one person who asked once like
is this just using mathematical tricks
to to sort of arrive at something and
it's like well yes and no and it's it's
there there tricks in that they allow us
to do certain kinds of things, um but
the important part is they do allow us
to do those things. So, I just I wanted
it to be clear that these aren't
deceptive things that we're we're doing.
It's just like kind of thinking through
the math such that you realize that you
can do these variational methods. That's
how we end up with this Q as a kind of
variational
belief or or posterior. So, that that's
the more involved answer, but all in
all,
bear with it. Uh I do I genuinely
personally believe that it's quite
rewarding as someone who did not have a
a background in mathematics, but but
just spending a little bit of extra time
like wrapping your head around is very
valuable.
Yes, very
very wise words from fellows who who
have gone uh down some of those paths.
There There's a lot to say on this like
depth in um learning
and how technical like
um and and as Fraser wrote, this isn't
just a um clinic for generative
modeling, but if people want to do a
workshop on just adopting
this code base
to their case
or PyMDP to the like those are the kinds
of things that we do in open science and
at the institute and that we we seek to
to scaffold collaboration around.
And like if you um
want to just find a technical
collaborator,
many people are looking for that.
That's the bigger rate-limiting step is
the expertise around these topics,
which is being partially um
um k- chaotically, but interestingly
bridged in many settings by coding
agents
and LLM chats, which which are able to
take a repo and adapt it to a similar
situation very um quickly.
And then like you're showing up for the
textbook group, you're actually leveling
up your own understanding,
which is going to be
um
from like the code and the math and
being
uh like a bigger apparatus
that is like every It's like a new city.
Like every corner is a new term or a new
new perspective
to um maintaining
core or understanding core central
repeated topics, of which there's a
pretty limited subset of,
and going out to the fringes and
building extensions and and elaborations
of.
And then like there's all of this kind
of more meta modeling discussion and
philosophy of science in terms of like
what does that generative model mean?
How are the outputs of computers and
synthetic intelligence systems related
to in just like kind of broader avenues.
So,
it's a textbook group, which is a broad
shape. It isn't just a coding group.
It's not just a math group. But
we can and and if people want to
spearhead this and and set a different
time or make up their own page to do
like the math learning group, as people
have done. Or there can be a code
learning group.
And so it's like
if you want to lead that and you don't
need to be the expert to lead it. That's
kind of the
meta active inference angle. Like
everybody is here, whether they're
jumping in live or they're watching the
YouTubes,
it's um
like you just jump in and and then you
find yourself at the front if you're
asking questions and curating resources
and making your your uncertainties
explicit and writing down multiple
thoughts,
feeding that through LLMs, asking around
in the community. That is like
indistinguishable from the research and
learning work itself.
So, hopefully that's
um
realized not just signaled in in how we
can participate in this group.
It's not like there's some qualification
hierarchy um
or or prohibition on questions. It's the
total opposite.
Yeah, good comments in the chat. The
2022 textbook and like
that that's a that that helped
many people over the previous years, but
there's like so many paths that it it's
you haven't missed any book if you
didn't read that one.
Everyone's just like joining the
carousel at sort of a different moment
in different different uh
different priors, different
orientations.
Again, some people they think they're
never going to touch code and 2 weeks
later
they're vibe coding.
Some people may rightly know that they
don't want to work on a computer.
They want to explore it in a different
direction. It's like that's part of
what's so cool about our
um community and ecosystem.
We We can actually have these very
diverse reading group experiences where
some people
it's just like what's in adjacency or an
affordance for them, a possibility for
them to do very easily
um cognitively or or academically or or
whatever.
That may be what someone else is looking
to do or wants to learn how to do.
And then we get to like not not like
skip to the good parts, but the really
um excellence
questions and and long-running discourse
around like the role of math in modeling
the role of physics in these different
in philosophy.
They're they're great topics and it's
like
if you're even wondering about that and
you want to know or you're curious about
why you're curious or something like
that, it's like you're already 100% in
the game.
Okay.
Does anyone want to point to a specific
question or section of two or
um
or vote on what questions they like in
the table?
Or we can look through some of these
questions, Fraser.
I'll just say really quickly with
respect to this issue of
marginalization, this came up as a kind
of central topic last week and in my
session as well.
Um I I did put this in the questions as
an answer to one of them, but page 438
in appendix C, so subsection C.2.3,
we talk about joint, conditional, and
marginal probability. There's a very
nice example there about performing this
operation called marginalization on a
very simple problem,
um discrete,
you know, prompt generative model. That
that really walks you through very
nicely what Well, at least in a very
simple way gives you some motivation as
to what this issue of marginalization is
all about. So, do have a look through
that. I wanted to mention that.
Yeah.
Okay.
Just I I just found this one image.
Here's like the joint distribution.
Like like a pile of sand on a table.
So, it's like height and weight
and then the pile of sand is each grain
of sand is a person and it stacks up and
that's the density
in this sort of like Z direction, like a
heap, like a heap, like a camp like a
hiking map
over this two-dimensional
two variables
two dimensions. So, that's the joint
distribution is the and.
And then the marginal is just like
flattening it one way or the other.
And then conditional is
um conditioned upon X being a given
value
what is the distribution? What's the
slice on that hill?
And then you get the conditional, like
what is the distribution over Y
given that X is a given value.
And then for a given instance, it's
going to have a particular value of X
and a particular value of Y.
But that's sort of like the the the
particle
data instance lens.
And then there's like the more
probabilistic distribution fields lens.
Andrew?
All right. Yeah, uh
I
I think you both provided nice
explanations regarding the
marginalization issue and then yeah, I
was just I wanted to directly answer one
of the questions in the code as well. Um
uh
I don't myself have a background in
anesthesia, but there's this question
regarding
um paper to page 27 about model evidence
and the marginalization and
intractability of model evidence. And
the question uh was effectively like why
is model evidence intractable there?
Um we use uh the area under the curve uh
in like these pressure waveform uh
functions whenever we're doing like
cardiac output measurements in
anesthesia.
Uh and I just thought that was a really
interesting example and potentially a
point to illustrate is that in this
anesthesia example, whenever you already
have this nice clean known function that
doesn't involve uh partial observability
and very large joint distributions
um kind of in line with what Daniel was
saying. It's like, well, we can have a
relatively simple model. It might be a
linear well-known model or it could be
um you know, a model that we tend to
look at in active inference where we
actually have, you know, a variety of
hidden state beliefs as opposed to
chapter two where we just have one
belief about the size of the food,
right? Um as it it typically modeled is
like a simple normal distribution and
not too much else. And then we have a
single observation modality, we will
call it, which is the light intensity.
Um and and it's there it's it would be
more than likely very easily tractable.
But then once we start adding in all of
these different variables and the the
space starts to expand, suddenly the
idea of being able to do real-time
estimates of cardiac output uh using
something that has all of this partial
observability and maybe a dozen more
variables involved, you'll you'll find
that it becomes quickly uh kind of kind
of broken in a sense without using some
kind of variational methods. And that's
ignoring anything regarding like
parameter learning, right? Cuz in the
cardiac output example, you have a known
function. And as we'll see in chapter
three, what happens whenever we don't
have like a fully known model and we
have to actually update not just our
beliefs like the X, um but also the
parameters of the model themselves like
changing the model and how it functions
in a sense. So, I hope that that was
useful in some kind of uh way for kind
of thinking about these things.
Thank you, Mark. And then anyone else?
Yeah, I was just going to say as you
were reasoning through that, Andrew, and
I appreciate that and I appreciate the
question. Um,
that uh something becomes partially or
unobservable as soon as we begin to make
a prediction. Is that right? So, we may
have perfect data,
but if we're going to use a model uh uh
uh uh uh uh as such, we're likely going
to be making predictions, and as soon as
we do that, we introduce uncertainty,
right? Isn't that sufficient to make
uh the tractability
um
and the uncertainty
where it needs to be to to be running
this type of methodology.
[clears throat]
Does So, in other words, that that as
soon as we begin to make a prediction,
we have an unknown, and therefore this
is the right
methodology. Is that Am I thinking about
that the right way?
Yeah, I'll just I'll try to answer
quickly, but generally, yes. Um, that's
a that's a great point. Like, we're here
in the partial observable environment.
The idea is we're we're
our our
our experience with the world around us
is kind of mediated through
um the the sensory information we
receive cuz another question in chapter
It was either asked in under chapter two
or chapter three, and which I also
answered there. Someone said like,
"Well, if X star or X asterisk, which is
that's the notation for the true
environmental state, they were like,
well, if that can never be known, then
what are we doing?" And I'm like, "Well,
that's that's exactly the point of all
this inference stuff. We have to try and
infer what it is using the sensory
information as the sort of like
mediator. Um, and it's what we make of
that sensor sensory information that's
very important and can lean towards uh
uncertainty. And while some might say
like, "Oh, well, if the the sky is if
the sun is out, I know it's daytime, so
why do I need to worry about all of this
uncertainty stuff?" But it's like,
"Well, if if um
you know, if if it's nighttime, but a
car passes you by and it has very bright
lights and suddenly you see all of this
light in your field of vision, um you
could do that simplistic forward mapping
and say, "Oh, I just saw a lot of light
at one time. It must be daytime, right?"
That would be the kind of naive, like we
don't allow for uncertainty,
um you know, sort of approach. But
someone who actually allows for
uncertainty and kind of has priors and
prior beliefs that they update, um they
say, "No, it it it's nighttime. I just
got partially blinded for a moment by
the light. That doesn't automatically
mean that it's daytime now, right?" It's
an odd like it's such a simple and odd
example to use, but it's this kind of
framework that it allows us to have this
kind of stability in our in our beliefs
and not just jump to conclusions about
about things. So I think I kind of
over-answered your your your question
mark, but I I don't Was that useful or
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, no, that was very good. And
I was just thinking about some of these
examples,
you know, we're we're making these
theoretical assumptions sort of in a
vacuum, but um it seems like embodiment,
you know, for an example, does a lot of
the work of the of the variational
stuff, right? We're we're constrained
by our senses. So it's it's almost as if
we start with and I'm thinking about
these these more theoretical papers like
we're just going to start with these
equations, right? These stochastic
stochastic differential equations and
then uh and then we're going to work
from there, but but some of this is like
it's already done
a priori in a sense. Like our priors
come from that. So we've already cut
through a lot of that. But I think we
need a common framework to begin with,
right? And that's the idea.
Yeah, yeah, and and and uh just briefly
like I mean, this idea of partial
observability or a more general sense of
updating one's beliefs using sensory
information, it's It's fairly ubiquitous
through a lot of sort of predictive
processing approaches. Like it's not
purely unique to active inference and
you know, it's I mean for those working
in like neuroscience or interested in
the concepts of perception like it's
it's like ubiquitous. Like yes, we don't
magically one-to-one know the world
around us. If that would even make sense
to say that, right? Like do Like we're
we're all born and learn a bunch of
language, right? This is all human kind
of constructed stuff that that we use to
like navigate the world, but at no point
is there like some, you know, master who
knows the real truth and they're able to
directly relay that to us. Anyway, I
Surely there are people who who disagree
with everything I just said, but to me
it was like I don't know. I I started
with the predictive processing and then
went to active inference. So I view
active inference in some ways it's like,
oh, this is like a natural outcome of
kind of the general paradigm shift
that's happened over the past couple
decades anyway. So it didn't appear as
like some
you know, there was no mystique about it
other than some of the difficult math.
So, yeah.
Yeah, these are great
great comments. This reminds me of a
book with with Friston's influence from
2016.
But a set of essays about like action
orientation and that kind of paradigm
change that Andrew alluded to there.
Um, and just like
uh,
that that was a very interesting comment
about what you said Mark about how in in
embodiment a lot of the work could be
done.
It's like none of the work of the
um,
Golden Gate Bridge is done by the map of
San Francisco.
It's like that's that's worlds apart.
But there is a reality to the
structural integrity of the Golden Gate
Bridge.
Um but that would be a different
artifact than than just a paper map.
Um and then the making simple
theoretical assumptions in a vacuum like
for people who have
who have explored math or statistics or
formal modeling, this is common to start
with something that seems like so simple
as to be kind of like head-scratching.
Because then we have the flexibility to
model like two metronomes on a table or
like a bunch of metronomes on a loosely
vibrating table.
Or these other kind of like more pure
and those types of settings first off
can be major
um intuition pumps for more complex
modeling like the two birds
in the setting where okay, the two birds
are are transferring semantic
information versus like
as um the sort of Friston and Frith bird
song research is like they both know the
same song. And so it's more like one
picking up when the other one drops off.
But maybe that's not the situation you
want to model. Maybe you want to model
one where they have different like part
A and part B of a song.
But you have like a a real ground to
stand on and have that discussion and
just distinguish those different models.
Um and then especially in a textbook and
in a learning setting these are like the
calisthenics is the very step-by-step.
So it's kind of like if you're on board
that the situation is partially
observable.
Which is to say like there are features
of your situation or an agent's
situation that are observed like
empirical data.
And there are situations that are
unobserved like the states or the
conditions giving rise to the
observations.
That's like
although on one hand it's very axiomatic
and a priori, it's also well justified
by
thermometers in in rooms. So it's a
pretty fair um
like
it it's not like we're in some contrived
universe to say that it's partially
observed. That's actually like the foot
in the door that helps us
surf uncertainty
and
explore all these different consequences
cascading from that. Well, like okay, so
if you're getting observations,
you want a general way to model how
observations and latent states are um
related. Well, that's just kind of like
signal processing.
And then you go, "Okay, well, what if
there's like action in the loop?" And
then there's learning the consequences
of action. And that's basically what
chapters 2 and 3
are going to walk through.
Like chapter 2
first is just focusing on that inbound
perceptual direction from one
observation and one latent state
to kind of saying like
that's just a dart on the board,
but like this is going to apply to
real-time streaming sequences of
observations
where you could have
any number of sensors for any number of
latent states.
Now, will your statistical power be
super low
if you have one if you're just getting
Morse code in and you're trying to infer
99 latent dimensions? Yeah, that's like
where information theory and kind of
fundamental constraints come into play.
Are there other situations that are very
over determined? Like you have 99
temperature sensors that you're getting
in your data set and there's just one
room temperature you want to infer?
Yeah, there might be a situation where
your empirical data are like
way overkill.
But
the framework
is not about one specific number of
sensors or latent states in chapter 2.
It's walking us step by step through
these kind of elaborations
from just that one data point to the
multiple sequential data points.
And then the whole pragmatic turn
which is like a broader philosophical
like zeitgeist
Gestalts, arc of history type thing has
to do with pragmatism and action.
So then you go, "Okay, we're going to
take the signal processing inbound
perceptual direction."
And then make a joint distribution over
perception, cognition, action, external
states.
And then that is where you start to get
into, "Okay, so then how does the agent
um we're going to start with an agent
that is going to already know the
consequences of its actions?"
And then we can go back a step. Okay,
how would a team A's agents learn the
consequences of its actions?
And then it's like so it's like there's
kind of a
um
logic
to starting pretty narrowly
with restricted modeling settings as
calisthenics
to to get familiar with how these terms
connect to each other.
And also to get a good gut check from
the philosophy of science side like what
you would or wouldn't be able to say
about thermometers in the room and the
temperature in the room.
It's a good it's it's it's not that it's
that it's um
always exactly what you'd say about a
social system,
but it helps give an analogy
um
for where a claim is already over
um confidence in a much trivial
situation
than in a less
comprehensively modeled
more
um
latent states and kind of like affective
and felt and all these other like kind
of features that people layer in
which are closer to their real world
curiosities.
But this is a textbook
that's showing us the the essence of
that
um
framework.
Just like a stats textbook will have a
lot of examples of distributions, but
then
if you're going to work in a given area
like
you you apply those distributions to
different data sets.
Any other like any any other
questions or thoughts on this?
>> [snorts]
>> Yeah, Fraser.
I did put this in the chat, but um I
thought I would just kind of say here
the the remainder of this chapter
is effectively so in that there's a lot
of exa- there's a lot of examples about,
you know, doing Bayesian inference and
looking at the mismatch between the
model and the generative process. So you
you go from really I would say the core
of this chapter
would probably be example 2.1,
2.2, 2.3,
2.4,
five and six.
Uh and then it kind of I would say it
ends really with um
uh section 2.3, so extending to multiple
samples. So we saw only we were only
taking in one sample, one observation
about what the light intensity was, and
we were doing our inference, and then we
were done.
But typically we take in multiple
observations.
So I would say, you know,
the the the the capstone of this chapter
is really kind of 2.3.
From there, that's not the end though,
because we we move into
uh 2.4 is a kind of a
a little bit of a di- well, not a
digression, but a a
bit more about what's going on inside
the generative model. 2.5 then says,
"Look, hidden state estimation without
Bayes' theorem." Okay? So,
all of 2.5 is about a different way to
do hidden state estimation that doesn't
that is not Bayesian, that doesn't
reason about uncertainty.
This is This is very interesting and uh
indeed some of these some of these ideas
are used in active inference later on,
especially the idea of gradient descent.
That's one way to go about
uh the sort of non-Bayesian ways of
doing things, but I just wanted to maybe
contextualize this idea about, you know,
maximum likelihood estimation or maximum
a posteriori,
non-Bayesian ways of of doing hidden
state estimation. This is not central to
active inference. This is kind of like a
getting a flavor of a different way to
do things. So, don't think that you have
to understand that in order to
understand things that are coming later.
You really don't. Um
I would say that really 2.3 is kind of
the end of this chapter, conceptually
speaking. So, I just wanted to maybe lay
that out there.
I'll just quickly follow up on that.
Yeah, I uh
and this is my own comment as well, but
I've never seen gradient descent so
quickly explained
uh in any book, paper, or otherwise. I
was just like, "Wow, this is uh there
are entire courses centered around this
in in
uh you know, at the undergraduate and
graduate level." And here we get, you
know, two papers that goes over two very
strong method, the maximum likelihood
expectation, maximum a posteriori
estimation with gradient descent. Um so,
very widespread in ML in machine
learning and so on, like Fraser said. Um
and uh it's a very big idea, the idea of
like iteratively kind of traversing like
the contours of like a state space or
otherwise, right? Um that that's very
big to be hit with that already at the
end of chapter two.
Um so, yeah, agreed that, you know, take
your time with understanding it. That
said, for anyone who is interested from
sort of the the the neuro side of
things, um part of what's interesting
about gradient descent whenever we think
about re-estimating beliefs iteration by
iteration is that in a lot of nice uh
papers dating as far back as, you know,
a decade to two ago,
um you know, in the context of both
predictive coding and in these POMDP
models we'll get into later, um whenever
you actually trace those iterations over
time and look at the weighted prediction
errors,
um that that that tends to be used as
like kind of an estimate of local field
potentials that that could be measured
from from neuroimaging data, which is
some of the stuff that brought me to
active inference. So, if for anyone who
that makes sense to, who's who's looked
at things like neuroimaging, local field
potentials, um
and signal processing and the rest, uh
it's a route there that we actually see
a more direct link with like why why are
we doing this gradient descent stuff?
Where's the empirical plausibility of
this stuff? So, worth uh worth checking
that out uh for anyone interested.
Yeah, a lot of lot of great questions.
Here's a written one.
In the infinite universe, so I mean, I'm
not sure how much that bears on the
question. I thought the probability PY
would be one.
Chat GPT said this is true, but PY is a
probability of observation Y occurring
in the generative model, so it can be
less than one.
Yeah, you can imagine that by the
definition of statistics, like a
statistics distribution versus a non
statistical distribution is basically
defined by having an area under the
curve of one
which is like 100%
which is to say something must happen.
Like a coin flip, something occurs. You
can model that as two, like a heads and
tails. You can model it as a three
state. You can model it as always coming
up with something like a one state
model.
Maybe that's not that informative.
Doesn't Maybe it doesn't get you that
paper published or whatever, but there's
like a lot of options, but they all have
the similarity that they all sum to one
as a probability distribution.
And then that connects to
um Giacomo asked
how does the agent select the priors?
Are there rational heuristics in play?
Like there's there's so many angles on
on that.
Um for a biological system
that's like the question of where do
priors come from?
So you could look at at evolutionary or
developmental models
that try to explain or or understand
like why a given prior exists.
Um
and then
here often the prior is just said this
is the prior. But with the code you can
try other combinations. And the whole
point of doing Bayesian modeling is like
you can test how different priors
affect your posterior.
So like the one of the signs of an
uninformative data set is your posterior
beliefs
are heavily based upon your priors. Like
if you try three different priors
like different shifted or different
families
and you get back three really different
outcomes, it's like suggesting that
basically there was little signal in the
data to update your beliefs and you were
getting something that was very prior
dependent.
Whereas if you have very different
priors that converge upon a similar
posterior belief
it suggests that the data are more
robust in supporting that conclusion.
Um
Yeah, and then and then what you just
wrote with like starting with uniform
and then using a variety of like
divergence minimization
and information theoretic criteria. Yes,
that's a great way to do it. And that
gets into a lot of other topics like
doing structure learning and how do you
look at model adequacy and and relevance
across portfolios of models that might
differ in like a little knob or might
have these massive structural
differences.
So, that's definitely part of the bigger
statistics and modeling discussion.
And in the textbook,
it starts from more of like the mainland
and builds out step-by-step
to familiarize you with with those
situations and trade-offs. It's not like
these um figures are like saying, "Oh,
and this is a breakthrough in fitting
the data well."
Many of them will model data more than
adequate adequately. Other ones, it's
just for you to get an intuition. Like
in in the the gradient descent,
um like it one kind of unlock for me in
thinking with the gradient descent was
like the linear regression
where you have two parameters you can
adjust. This is a setting that's in
chapter two. The intercept and the
slope.
And for each of those intercept and
slope,
you can think about how the the loss
function
looks like a quadratic.
Like if you are above the data points
with your regression and you keep on
pushing it up, it just gets worse and
worse and worse.
And then as you pass through the middle,
the mean trend,
you kind of like on the bottom of a
bowl.
Either for just the intercept or just
the slope or like the two-dimensional
bowl for both.
Because it's a convex optimization. So,
you can pursue these like gradient
descent methods.
And when you do a linear regression in R
or Python or whatever,
that may be what's happening under the
hood.
And this is like working with that idea,
but instead of just looking at the
squared residual of the data points,
we can look at something that's a little
bit different.
But, understanding the continuity
between what active inference is talking
about
and machine learning and parametric
statistics
is a key contribution of this book.
And as Andrew mentioned,
like gradient descent is itself a a
large topic.
And so, understanding which statistical
algorithms are
amenable to this incremental
gradient descent-based fitting,
what tolerance threshold before you
declare that a given convergence
is um
appropriate?
Is there ever a situation where it looks
like it's converging and then it goes
into another drop, which is like called
grokking in the neural networks?
Like there there's so many
related discussions
in machine learning, deep learning,
which is just computer statistics.
Like as they say, computers don't play
chess, they just do statistics, but they
don't do statistics, they just follow
physics.
I think that was some
Hofstadter-related quote.
Any last question or or thing?
Otherwise, we will stop the recording.
All right, I'm going to stop the
recording though. Thank you.
And we'll hang around for a few minutes.